I think this is the story that I I know
you wanted to share let's talk about
that be clear he does not want to share
this story but yeah I thought your
audience would love it I love you I
think though I love you thank you for
doing that the failed successes seem to
be the hot story Vayner Nation how are
you we are really excited about this
episode of the podcast because we're
going to talk about entrepreneurship
we're going to talk about the
entrepreneurial Journey that I know a
lot of you are on the highs the lows but
we're going to talk about one of my
favorite subject matters so before I
introduce these two great guests and
what they're up to I have to give a huge
shout out to Jordan Syed who was my
trainer for three years uh Mike vacanti
introduced me to him Mike vacanti's now
back in my trainer they put out a book
recently by the way I should have given
that a little more love uh they have
some funny stories about me including
one time when I ate an obnoxious amount
of baked beans at Citi Field
um and was not happy with my weight but
you know as I got to know these
gentlemen and were were pondering some
fun stuff together I'm very passionate
about what they're doing for a living
because I grew up with that quote
unquote bad back my whole life I was a
senior in high school
17 years old and just in the middle of
the night woke up and it was the
scariest thing that ever happened my
back like my back quote unquote went out
I had no idea what's going on I was in
the most pain that I'd have ever been in
my life and I couldn't walk and I like
scrawled scraped my way to my parents
room had no idea was going on my family
is very old school Eastern European
Russian so it was basically like just
take this Tylenol go to sleep there was
no like I mean the amount of compassion
kids get now compared to what I got is
like
I mean like people get a splinter and
get 10 times more than I got I couldn't
I just want to remind everybody I could
not walk it's 3 30 in the morning my mom
was like here's some here's some Tylenol
go to sleep here's the funny part I
didn't go to school that day because
that they had compassion for I wake up
and I'm perfect I wake up at like 10 30
which is cool because I couldn't sleep
for a couple hours I wake up I'm perfect
perfect as if it didn't happen I have no
idea what happened my mom then says she
has to run an errand and I go with her
we go to the Phillips Brook Mall in New
Jersey and the huge sign at the
Phillipsburg Mall says baseball card
show today my mom looks at me and
thought I made it up to trick her so I
could go to the basement but that day
became the Journey of what became a
20-year Journey before Jordan side came
into my life and taught me about my ql
taught me about the stretches taught me
about soft tissue did the work and for
years and years and years I've done the
work and my back is in by far the best
shape it's ever been in ironically I've
started playing basketball again we
played a lot of basketball over a
two-day period And I actually tweaked it
for the first time ever and like by the
way this morning instead of the chest
workout I had Mike vacanti and I did 45
minutes of soft tissue rolling against
it so this is very intriguing timing
because what I also learned and I know
I'm doing a huge intro but I really want
to go there because I think a ton of you
are going to want to know about and talk
about what we're talking about here when
covet came
I wasn't doing as much as my regular
stretching just it was this I was in my
house the non-gym setting didn't have me
do my warm-up as much I was kind of
doing the Bowflex thing and just like
all weights I was focused on it and I
really felt the effects after 18 24
months of when I was talking to Mike and
even occasionally Jordan
um it was funny I thought it was the
lack of stretching and then the
conversation that we're about to get to
really started hit my radar when Mike
said it's the sitting
and that really really triggered me
because where I got caught was I wasn't
sitting a lot when I was 17 16 and so I
never Associated my injury with sitting
what I in hindsight do understand was
starting at 22 because I was building
a.com I sat an enormous amount and I
reinforced my issues in all those years
of sitting
um I'm setting that up and now I'm going
to introduce these two wonderful
gentlemen and it will all make sense of
why I've told these stories and what
we're talking about here today so men
thank you for being on the show thanks
thanks for having us why don't you tell
the Vayner Nation individually who you
are and what you do
yeah my name is Eric Murphy I'm one of
the co-founders and CMO of anthros and
I'm Steve Dufresne I'm one of the
co-founders and the inventor and CEO of
anthros wonderful so now to connect the
whole thing why don't both of you
whoever wants to take the mic tell the
story of what is anthros go forward
Murph
yeah I would say just at a very high
level we are the company that set out to
create the most comfortable supportive
office chair the world has ever seen to
help people with pain and maximize
performance
so at a very high level that's the
that's the outcome we're trying to
produce and why do we have the authority
to make those wild claims we worked with
the disabled population and worked with
people in wheelchairs for the last 20
actually 70 plus years as a collective
team so the amount of research data
science that had to go into the products
that we were making for the disabled
population which are the most intense
sitters on the face of the planet as you
can imagine it wasn't just about Comfort
or discomfort it was about in some cases
life or death right if you have the
wrong equipment of course and you're
sitting in your chair all day long every
day that's a huge deal so for us what we
have is just a different way of seeing
sitting and we may not be experts on a
lot of things but we can sit here today
and say that we know sitting better than
99.9 of the population so for you know
that was an eye-opener for me of course
I'd friends who started standing desk
startups so I had a lot of thesis of it
but I think for anybody listening no
question the last 10 years you started
hearing like sitting is the new smoking
it was a you know thing I've heard in
different business settings there's been
a bigger conversation to health and
wellness over the last 30 years across
the board mental health physical health
like I don't even recognize popular
culture it's it's wonderful like just
the way people what people are putting
in their bodies how we're thinking about
and it makes sense like you know like I
never thought that this would be the way
I would look at 47 when I was 15 because
47 year olds just didn't take care of
themselves the way we all do and I'm not
even like really I'm like solid but like
there's people really looking crazy at
50 and 60 and 70 and so this is just
great this is why we're living longer it
all makes sense but what what are the
things that we're missing let's start
with sitting for a second because I'm
fascinated by it what what what are the
misconceptions what are the realities
what can you share with the audience
about sitting yeah like anecdotally for
the big one setting is the new smoking
man that one that one really chaps us
going it's not that bad actually and if
you look at the evidence
um standing is the new smoking not
sitting tell me
standing is more detrimental for your
spine and your body than sitting because
that [__] gravity dissect the
human body and you dig in and you you
once everything to me are you saying so
are you saying hence why you're doing
this startup
are you saying that your chair based on
what you're about to tell me next is
better for you than a standing desk
why
when you can stand sure yeah you'd think
that's hot standing is important right
it is both are very important of course
and it's not better than the other put
everything in life right we would like
to start with the asterisks alcohol
better than the other misplay it is bad
yeah alcohol not misplayed is solid go
ahead easily is important so with the
asterisks fair enough when you stand yes
you turn on every muscle in your body to
stand up especially if you're going to
stand properly yes a lot of muscle
chains on yes and you can only exert
that much energy for so long before you
lean on the desk two arms on the desk
then you slide the laptop forwards even
more and you lean even farther and now
you're sitting with a really in a bad
back position and then you're crossing a
leg and you're leaning this way and that
way and you're really not doing what you
really know what that out to do you know
what's so funny brother you know what
just happened in my head when you were
saying that huh so cliche to things I
believe about human behavior
the individuals that are most excited
about getting a standing desk
oftentimes are looking for the hack that
works for them
which also then means that they aren't
as interested in putting in the work to
build up all the muscle that they would
need to actually get the advantage of a
standing desk because the amount of
muscle that one has to create to
actually take advantage of like not
being fatigued over a period of time and
standing it's like it's like this
[__] dude I know there's some good
[__] under that shirt I can tell I can
tell I see it from a mile away I know
it's good it's like you got to be like
that to actually like do something right
yeah yeah because if you're standing
incorrectly and you're doing that eight
hours a day all of a sudden that you're
just adding strength to dysfunction
right so then the hypothesis becomes
cool since we're gonna sit anyway since
like that's interesting okay keep going
but I would say the second part of that
is performance so okay we look into the
research we look at in the data and when
you are standing you conscious or not
you're hijacking some of your ability to
focus on what what you're what you're
working on so when you're sitting in a
chair that supports your body you can
shut off your muscles you can relax then
100 of your attention is going to what
you're focusing on so I think it's from
both a pain and you know injury
perspective but also just a performance
it's an interesting question I'm curious
what you're going to say from a
standpoint of like it's leg day it's AB
day it's like right like that whole
thing is there a regimen for certain
people that
would be nice for them to do a mix like
is it good to sit in this chair five
days a week but two days a week do the
standing desk like I think it's more
it's it's a shorter time frame than it's
like why don't you sit an hour and stand
an hour sit in our standing hour sit an
hour stand 20 minutes or maybe not an
hour of standing maybe maybe even
shorter window of standing because you
have to take faster
so sit in our stand 10 minutes move
around then sit down again when you sit
well yeah don't slouch if your body
allows you have to stand eight hours a
day in the perfect position and you can
do that without creating any kind of
dysfunctional in your body then great
you know what's so funny I just thought
of something I actually pitched Mike on
a startup
that plays in this slouching thing so I
had something happen a different time
and Mike got me this thing right that I
put over myself like what is that thing
like a posture remind me yeah thank you
and like you know it really tight like
whatever and I don't remember it might
have been my back thing but I just
remembered telling him like yo we need
to create a product where like I was
like my bigger problem is when I'm
sleeping when I'm sleeping I go fully
Primal into baby mode I'm like like I'm
so [__] up I'm like I'm like baby Yoda
like I'm I don't know what I'm doing but
I'm doing something I'm with you there
I'm so bad dislocated show and I was
like bro I have to like and actually the
shoulder thing now I'm I used to sleep
through the night all the time lately
this is very recent last six months I'm
waking up once or twice a night because
my shoulders and I don't know like like
I'm actually doing all the right things
more I don't know what I did that made
this thing happen but I was like Mike we
need I need this thing I want to sleep
with it and it's funny you should
mention sleep with sitting right now
because those two are best friends and
most people just don't realize it notice
what I did no YouTube a great segue
thank you brother so wait so after you
guys are done with this startup can you
create like a sleeping chamber that
makes me like be like a vampire and just
like be pot like honestly
the thing that's cool about the Sleep
one is like I just would love to be
straight as an arrow for seven hours
because I'm sleeping anyway it feels
like I'm not doing the work which is fun
that's the problem the problem with the
world
Health Fitness posture you know all of
it Mental Health
people really struggle doing the work
that doesn't come natural to them I have
unlimited Fitness buddies who all look
like you two who like just don't want to
actually work eight hours a day on their
business and I laugh because I'm like
they're like asking me every shortcut
the same way I'm asking them like hey
can I get like the apple cider vinegar
[__] or can I get like AB implants
or can I like what's this new thing that
every [__] person is now taking so
they don't [__] eat the diet like the
[__] like people just always looking
for the the shortcut
which is why this intrigued me and why I
want to do this show which is like
there's not a lot of things that are
easy actually to make your life better
it's why medicine's so like loved and
revered like you take it and things can
get better this kind of felt very
practical to me I'm like wow especially
when Mike put the propaganda of like and
not the propaganda like start I use that
as a slang term so I want to be clear
here when Mike educated me of like the
sitting thing is a thing and it makes
sense because my this like whatever
what's this like what's that yeah but
like this yes the psoas that
[__] the amount of work I have
like that [__] is so tight yeah and
that's all from this horse [__] like
like Anyway nonetheless
you can do yoga and pilates and put in
the [__] work which everyone should
but what really [__] me up was I did
put in the work for three years and
fixed so much and then one 18-month
window of a global pandemic where I
changed my behavior
really it really was I'll be very Frank
with you disheartening because it's
cliche I lost 20 pounds over a year and
a half and I put in all the work and
[__] nine months later it's all back
because you changed your behavior back
to the bad behavior that's probably the
thing that I most want to talk to you
about which is like because I think it's
a by the way for everyone who's
listening there's a very selfish episode
for me because I hope this brings an
idea for you that's your version of this
startup for them meaning I think there's
still a lot of inventions to be made
that will like put training wheels to
people on things that are hard let me
give you like another comp that nobody
talks about the reason I thought
musically was going to be big which
ended up becoming Tick-Tock and I get
all that credit is because I understood
that it was helping people make content
easier that if you look at what happened
with social media over the last decade
the tools now between green screen this
and filter that and music this and split
screens that it's become a production
infrastructure it's an Adobe suite
that helps people that couldn't do what
I did which was like you just had to go
and talk and that had to carry the day
so I love this concept of training
wheels things that make things easier
this chair really helps everyone but
someone like me who's really emotional
about his back pain over the last 20
years it's like really an interesting
product and I'm sure a lot of other
people out there a are going through
this but then B to be honest because I
know my audience here I'm hoping this
episode inspires them to do their
startup that helps people do something
they don't want to do
speaking of inspiring tell us about the
adversity story oh I'd love to but I'd
like to touch quick on something because
he said the posture trainer please and
and sleeping and tied into the mattress
and posture training yes and that's
exactly what a chair that you can do
this can help you sit up better actually
let's talk about the show we're kind of
like yapping like I have this whole
my own agenda right now which is I'm
hoping somebody invents something so
profound and they say my podcast didn't
I get all the credit then there's also I
really want you to talk a little bit
because I know a little bit about
backstory because I think a lot of
people go through adversity before they
get to their place but actually
one more time the.com of the chair and
more importantly like what does it
actually do
throws yep.com yep and it's just a play
on the Greek root word of human anthro
and that was our principle for Designing
the chair it wasn't to design the chair
for an office worker or a gamer or a or
a blogger it was to design a chair for a
human being and we all have the same
needs we don't have green blood and
purple blood we all need the same kind
of input the same kind of love and a
chair can hurt you or it can help you a
chair can a chair can feel comfortable
you can fall asleep in it or it can be
like a park bench and be painful where
you can't wait to get off of the dang
thing and that's what we tried to invent
as a chair that can help change your
posture over time and you're feeling
that when you make those little
adjustments to the two backs you were
changing your posture and use it as a
tool instead of the strap that your
trainer had to put on you're using your
chair to get your which is so much more
scalable yeah nobody wants to wear a
weird strap at night yeah but people
just sit in chairs yeah
so change your posture over time and
actually we we worked pretty hard to get
the chair registered with the FDA as a
sitting orthotic it is it is qualified
to change your posture over time and one
of the big claims that we make going try
the chair feel the truth this is the
softest cushion you're ever going to sit
on is this it the human this is back to
like muscle gain and all the stuff I
learned like the the way your body mind
thing works you're saying micro deposits
on a daily basis that over time actually
changed the way you're like walking and
sitting and standing yeah that's yeah
definition of an orthotic is changing
posture over time which is what this
this chair allows you to do
on top of that we guarantee because we
have testing University Testing we we
took all of the leading office chairs
that we could find threw them into a
seating engineering lab and said can you
guys test these and see which ones
perform at the highest level in terms of
measures of comfort and you can guess
who who won that who won that test a
bunch of the bunch of wheelchairs
sitting nerds of course
tell us something you know I think this
is a story that I I know you wanted to
share let's talk about that sure be
clear he does not want to share this
story but yeah I thought your audience
would love it I think they'll uh thank
you for doing that
the failed successes seem to be the hot
story tell us uh I'm 47 I just turned
47. yeah and uh this is literally the
anniversary 20 years ago I was 27 years
old and I started a business uh bringing
a power wheelchair to Market with a
really unique feature on it that kind of
uh raised the seat up 22 inches sounds
kind of weird like a an accordion thing
but if you're sitting all day long you
can't reach in your upper cabinets you
can't see somebody eye to eye and on and
on and on and on right so raising them
up to function in a walking world is a
no-brainer so brought this thing to
Market was doing really good raised uh
what 27 28 raised uh I don't know almost
2 million dollars had seven partners and
launched it was traveling all over the
U.S showing the chair off to all the VA
hospitals things were going great and I
came across an investor uh uh kind of on
a fluke a new angel investor and I was
reading Inc magazine 2017 entrepreneur
of the year and it was a local Wisconsin
guy that had done really good for
himself and then there he talked about
man when I was uh if I could go back in
time I I'd work with the banks
differently I changed my whole
relationship and I was like I wonder
what he means by that because I'm in the
startup mode what what should I know so
the old-fashioned way I wrote a letter
with a pen and licked an envelope and
put a sticker on it and uh lo and behold
he reached out and invited me down to
meet him shocked that he responded right
that guy's a billionaire I think he'd
give me the time of day but he's the
kindest guy I've met in the business
world so
rode down there met the guy shook his
hand told him my story and in one hour
uh that was it I wanted him to be a part
of this business and he wanted to be in
and buy everybody out and
what can I do for you what do you need
right now to to keep winning
I said I need like 25 Grand you know my
monthly burn rate's hot right now and
he's like okay stop by the front desk
for for a check for twenty five thousand
dollars and we'll talk in a couple weeks
it's like what did you just say
you don't even have my home address I
don't even know if you have the spelling
my last name
last name you want to give me a check
for 25 000 on a handshake man
of course you're like the fairy
Godfather right so uh this relationship
went on and a number of months of doing
exactly what he said and uh
um
The Story Goes that literally uh you
learn the
no deals done until it's done right that
simple little adage yep uh literally a
handful of days before the contract was
signed by both of us he was buying all
my partners out and going to move down
by him and you know right off into the
sunset yeah with this power wheelchair
we're going to change lives within a
billionaire background I mean how much
more can you ask for in your early 20s
yeah yeah early 20s in 2017 it was 2000
yeah I was
27. yeah I was listening carefully yeah
that threw me up for a half a second but
I thought that's what it was I just want
to clarify it for the audience so here
you are you're I mean you're someone who
gave you 25k kind of blindly like it
it's everything's checking the boxes
you're literally within the week of him
buying out the rest of investors at the
same valuation or an inflated value ah
it was going to be inflated yes they're
exactly right right and
and I got a phone call saying that he
had a tragic
death out of the blue right you know oh
so you know this was setting up as like
it was funny the way you were selling
the story like that I thought you were
building up the drama of like this was
the nicest guy but it wasn't the nicest
guy oh no he's the nicest guy oh in
business that's what I ever met like you
want to talk about the definition of
philanthropy that is this guy I almost
jumped in and said right you know if
it's too good to be true it is that's
why you didn't say that
holy [__] you're a week away from this
thing and this gentleman passes away
tragically yeah and we we mentioned it
was 07 right so I'm going into 08
January of 08 right the whole world
changed the whole world did change and
just like maybe it's happening now and
that burn rate was still there right and
he owned like 30 other companies and you
know wow it's just Faith you know you
can't change fate it was it was meant to
be exactly so hard to swallow hard to
swallow yes especially when you felt
like you were the top of the world right
you know a day before and now I'm very
into my thesis of like gratitude for
like you just don't know like seemingly
like every you know yeah you don't know
you know this is very thank you by the
way for making him share this real talk
real talk because the answer might not
be even now like how long did it take
you to comprehend that to get to a place
where you could say it was just meant to
be versus like how did this happen to me
what are the odds all that stuff oh
that's can you sorry to interrupt can
you slip in the quick little story of
the the moment where you kind of had the
this is this is the worst about can you
tell the worst moment of the story Steve
it's it's kind of the bottom moment
where you look at how old was the
General when this gentleman when he
passed Maybe 60.
terrible okay go ahead okay so um this
moment happens right and uh it only
takes a handful of months to go by
before uh they they six seven eight
months go by and they're like sorry
we're liquidating all of his companies
unless it dealt with the main company
and yours doesn't qualify as one of
those so now I've been I don't want to
say strung out but the burn rate was
going the deals
was done but it's not done now and now
I'm in like June July of 08 looking for
money okay and my existing Partners were
Mortgage Bankers uh Builders all in the
wrong trades basically to keep funding
this company so I was done I was just my
goose is cooked so
I was the managing director of the LLC
and as you know all bankruptcies slide
through that individual so I took the
loss as did my wife at the time of the
business failing and um that was a lot
of strain on us and that was the end of
the relationship so the divorce kicked
off at the exact same time as this
and uh now I was asked to turn in all my
assets right so this is the moment that
uh is is the tough one
it's a drive your vehicles down to the
auction please
okay so I drove the first one down and
was very embarrassed back then I was I
was kind of down and out so I hitchhiked
my way back home took about an hour or
so got back home and thought that was
stupid I got a better idea I'm gonna put
this moped in the back of the other
vehicle and I drove the other one down
to the auction and pushed the moped out
and uh you know thought okay it's
normally an hour drive on the expressway
and I've got to take all these country
roads in January yeah in Wisconsin with
you know
my best coat and pants on that I can in
a snowmobile helmet no goggles and you
know looking like a nut job who's riding
a moped in January Wisconsin to begin
with let alone crying the whole way I
also would love it yeah just literally
crying the whole way home I mean the
crocodile tears you know freezing your
face and chipping them off and
especially when your brain up you know
three weeks earlier I don't know the
timing here yeah but like how many days
earlier you think it's completely on the
other side of the equation yeah it
happened so fast yeah and then you get
you get back to the the the building
it's like well I don't have a place to
live and all that I have left in this
building is a pallet with like six bags
of clothes on it two speakers my gas
grill and my yellow lab happy to see me
yeah and uh the Dig back question is is
easy
uh
and and you say it all the time you you
don't have much time to feel bad for
yourself when you start getting hungry
no job no checking no savings no Bank no
cars no house no place to stay you're
homeless it's just you and your dog and
you're hungry so what did you do you
hustle you take any job what did you
stay I couch surf at some friends houses
you know started far and
and narrowed it in you know you can only
do that for so long too and and there's
no job that I wouldn't do I mean clean
gutter clean up poop yeah pressure wash
yep put a floor in what do you want done
so for two years I just hustled and then
what happened
and then
what's really interesting is this yeah
what was supposed to happen the
interesting thing is
you could say that I was a little bitter
than like this wheelchair thing ruined
my life okay there is some of that of
course you're a young man at this point
yeah like ruined my life someone in
their late 20 this is why I talk about
all my content like when you're 29
you're not gonna walk around Earth with
a 47 year old you know perception you're
not gonna walk around Earth with a 74
year old perception you're definitely in
like that place 29 30. you know where
you know there was totally comment today
on my social I don't know why it
triggered me so much literally literally
it's what I get all the time oh I know
what it was I I did my there was a very
very viral video for me years ago of me
outside saying this could be the last
Monday of your life you could have been
a bus it went very viral at the time for
a lot of people today it's still to this
day it was the first time they ever saw
me because it was when Facebook fan
pages were going and we hit and we
reposted on Instagram for the first time
in forever and literally there was a I
was just looking at it this morning like
24 hours later just kind of reading some
of the comments and someone's like
you know like yeah but like like not
really because like I am lost I'm 25 and
all my friends are doing X Y and Z and
the thing that I always find interesting
is especially at 28 29
30 [__] up everyone under 30 in such a
wild way every single person 17 to 29
has this crazy bad relationship with 30.
as if it's like I'm 47 and I'm like 30
is a child right and and the world's
younger now and a lot of people do like
live more child life at 30 than they did
back when everybody was getting married
at 20 and would have 10 year olds and 30
just you know two generations earlier
but you know at that to be back to your
story because we're of that same age
like not only were you struggling those
two years some of your high school
friends and some of your acquaintances
and cousins and Friends really quote
unquote had their life figured out
already oh they did and that really
[__] with people that's where people
get real right people get really down on
themselves especially when and this is
this is why this story is so important
thank you for making me share this
because this is good for my audience
especially when a month or two or three
earlier youth thought you were going to
be ahead of all your friends this is com
this is what I why I'm obsessed with
comparison comparing your life to
anybody else's life is the great mistake
of everyone's life because it will put
you in such a bad place regardless
either you'll think you're too good
which is maybe where yeah I don't know
you like maybe where you were a month
earlier because you're like wait do I
have this big wait everybody hears which
is always bad that's a vulnerability or
the one that's much more prominent which
is you think you suck because you called
out the most successful person you know
of your I love how people do it Gary you
don't get it my neighbors sister's best
friend just built a million dollar
company I'm like what about your 80
other loser friends why don't you
compare it to yourself like people will
pick out the one Mark Zuckerberg like
Mark Zuckerberg what the [__] are you
talking about all 20 of your roommates
suck why don't you compare yourself to
them like why people just love to bash
themselves like for no [__] reason in
your late 20s when you get to that zero
of a place that fast from a place that
was on the verge of putting a lot of
paper value around you must have been
challenging
it was but I really go back to I was
like how'd you do it how'd you do it
it's like man I was just hungry and I
wanted I'm a doer I want to take care of
me I didn't want to of course fall upon
the system so guess what I'm gonna sling
concrete I'm gonna put your roof on for
you I'm gonna I'm gonna remodel your
kitchen for you but I'm taking care of
me and in this case it was just me and
my dog yeah of course
how did you so what what happened next
how did you get to this point well
that's a quick transition believe it or
not after two years it just side jobs
hustle and just staying alive I mean
literally
um the company when I was making this
power wheelchair I designed everything
but the seating
I bought the seating system from another
Local Company okay called The Comfort
company okay and this company reached
out to me you know two years later going
hey man what are you up to you you're
not doing the wheelchair thing anymore I
am like no no I'm not why don't you come
work for us interesting no wheelchairs
ruin my life no thank you oh no [__] at
first oh yeah it was a salad no you were
still there I was yeah yeah so you want
to know how long I can tell you two
years later apparently I was still a
little bitter because I I said no to him
and literally the the the the weird part
is I got in the car politely told him no
hey man thanks for the offer but I'm
gonna find something else to do
wheelchairs yeah man that might dig I
get maybe two blocks down the road
and I had the most thermal nuclear
emotional blow up out of nowhere I had
to pull the car over and I had no clue
why and it was more like how dare he
make me think about wheelchair people
you are again I can't believe that he's
trying to make me come back into this
thing
no it ruined my life and then you know
two weeks later after titling your
friends and family they're like you're
an idiot this is who you are you love
this it's who you were meant to be just
go take the job and get your ass back in
there and I did and they saved me and
then I got back into the wheelchair
Community again serving them this time
not with power chair now it's with
seating how did you go all the way back
how did you first get into the
wheelchair Community before even before
how did you invent that like what was
your first experience with it that's a
quick one Uncle Bob my Uncle Bob
um as a disability I've grown up around
it he's been in a manual chair power
chair his entire life and he's a he is
an entrepreneur he owns a landscaping
company and climbs on and off tractors
and skidsters equipment and if you saw
him you'd go I cannot believe this guy
does this so you want to talk about the
definition of tenacity it's a blob yeah
I saw this chair that goes up and down I
was like man if if Uncle he had one of
those or anybody like him scratching
your own inch from you it's just like
profound all right we're gonna we're
gonna run out of time what have we not
we didn't get we're like that was by the
way you should not do this chair
business
and you should be a professional
Storyteller because that was extremely
good now now CMO I know why you can do
that I was like why like that wasn't
pretty audience that was putting him in
the platform of what he should really be
like why does everybody want this story
I just want to sell chairs I did this
story you're a very very good
Storyteller that was really cool
um
so actually because I'm going to get
rushed out of here like what what didn't
we touch on that you thought of like
obviously wanted to talk about like
first I'm like pretty sure before I die
I will have a soft tissue business
because you know not to the level of the
emotion I think comes with an Uncle Bob
who's in a wheelchair but like my back
was foundational in my life for 20 years
like I didn't I didn't I didn't I didn't
sit on a certain side of airplanes
for 15 years because I knew if I fell
asleep that there was a chance it could
lock yeah yeah right so it was a real
part of my life like you know really you
know it's amazing what you'll just
accept
I was just like that's my life I have a
bad back and it was just like so
solvable through just tissue work and
stretching and like strength and it's
just like I'm like wow [__] and this is
why I'm so passionate about this single
podcast the thought of like you know you
know at some level you guys care quite a
bit of people get this chair I'm just
trying to get people educated in my
audience about like the chair thing and
like yes of course it'd be awesome if
they get excited about this but like I
just want people to know yeah it's kind
of like it's kind of like in the 70s I'm
sure someone was like this cigarette
thing is not as good as people think
like we should talk about it more or
like or like the things we're going
through now like this this this the way
we're sitting is a real thing and like
really matters what what do we what do
we not touch on in the last two minutes
here that we should touch on anything
set out we could probably tie that into
go right from the comfort company thing
now that's yeah we could just jump into
how did you do something we did seating
for 10 years right and you guys met
where he was yeah we're mad at that
seating company 15 years ago so oh you
were there yeah he was always product
yeah product side of things that was
marketing and so we brought products to
market for the last 15 years together
that's awesome yeah at what point did
you know you guys wanted to work
together
like in a different capacity
yeah I mean I think uh man that was
probably 10 maybe eight years ago we
started transparently he was uh upset at
our then president yeah and he said he
seems like that kind of guy I think he's
still got some feelings and they're like
I'm watching him carefully I'm not sure
I can turn it anymore that's it I'm out
of here
I got an idea we're out of here it's
like we should do office chairs do you
think that's entrepreneurial passion do
you feel like that's engineering DNA
like hey this isn't as good as it can be
like what triggers that I'm kind of the
curious guy that likes looking for
problems then finding Simple Solutions
big Solutions my my wife would tell you
that my favorite phrase is I got an idea
yep yeah
well I mean
I know we're short on time here but I
think
and throw us what we want we just want
to be part of peop for their people who
know what it's like to wake up at 4am
and work till midnight the people who
are chasing their dreams sacrificing
everything getting zero recognition for
the people like you who've experienced
chronic pain yeah and will never take
for granted not being a pain again we
think that we can be part of you know
part of that journey and and we're
cheering those type of people on I love
that brother a couple things there's so
many little thick stories I want to tell
I used to when I first started working
out it was wild Jordan pointed this out
to me the weight like when I'd have to
pick it up to do like some sort of thing
on the right side I would just pick it
up and on the left side I would pivot my
entire body to be able to do it because
I couldn't do it straight yeah and like
I'm bringing this up at the like random
thoughts here because I'm just I'm
telling people like I don't think people
realize that they don't need to accept
being in pain because they don't think
they have time to fit or money to fix it
not that this chair is [__]
inexpensive but like it's like to me
it's just so [__] worth it like like
grabbing my luggage from the top out of
the air like it's just like it's an
everyday thing when you don't realize
you know hey I honestly I also think I'm
doing a PSA for just gaining strength
like like like it's really scary how big
of a deal that is especially legs like
we're talking about this off line like
it really matters and nobody wants to do
leg days like I literally when Mike says
Bulgarian but squads I literally like
cry still every month later not walking
down steps but [__] it's so worth it so
like you know both gaining strength just
just make this very broad we talk so
much about perspective and mentality on
this show this is going to the other
side of it which is like you just don't
have to
be in this situation like there are a
lot of ways to do and I do think sitting
like is a category of conversation that
needs to have a lot more talk and like
obviously the chair but there's
obviously other variables that you could
be doing and I think I I hope this
inspired some people to actually go down
this rabbit hole because I'm looking
forward to the DMS and emails in a year
because it is a big deal for me and for
a lot of other people and uh and I'm
cheering for you guys and I wish you
well yeah thank you very much thanks I
appreciate it